so you may remember that new york city
got rid of the reign of terror of bill
de blasio the socialist maniac who
ruined new york city for about eight
years and they voted in this other
democrat mayor eric adams who just took
over in the last couple months who once
again my my good liberal friends who i
suppose are well intentioned but ever
get everything wrong they said no he
won't be a radical he'll be good
yeah well here he is keeping kids
toddlers toddlers in masks if you were
talking to a four-year-old and they're
trying to explain why they have to keep
their mask on but their their
six-year-old brother doesn't what what
is your your explanation to that
four-year-old
i'm so happy you said that because when
i was in rockaway in the saint pat state
parade i did just that a group of
parents brought me and talked to their
children and explained to them i told
them you're going to be taken off your
mask like your big brothers and sisters
are doing now you know when when you
have big brothers and sisters sometimes
they do things first to make sure it's
safe for you and those children they
understand it because they trust their
parents and they trust their leadership
they're not tainted like adults you know
they still feel
that we have to make the right decisions
for them and i'm with the parents i want
those masks off i said it in january but
i have to do it right to make sure city
protect his children and don't close
down the city again
we really live in two different
countries perhaps it's more than two
different countries at this point but i
i don't live in the same country as that
man i don't want to live in the same
country is that man i want people like
him to have absolutely nothing to do
with me and that is why right now we are
building a giant moat around my house as
i said the other day we're putting we're
filling it with gators and i just put an
order in we we sent the the paperwork
over to israel i'm getting an iron dome
system around my house i want nothing to
do with these people now notice of
course let's just do the easy stuff up
top he didn't say one thing about
science right so there is 100
no science that has
come out anywhere that it says that
toddlers he's talking about two and
three-year-olds have to be uh masked
while they're older brothers who should
do stuff before them
while they don't have to be masked okay
so there's no sign so he quoted no
science there
and then
the line that really gets you
these kids he's talking about these
toddlers they're not tainted like adults
think about what that means what he's
right they're not tainted like adults
kids come into this world and they're
they're born free and they're they're
naive the world is just the world is
what is put in front of them and then
they need adults to teach them how to
think they need adults to teach them
what freedom is and to be able to
critically think about what's going on a
toddler cannot do that so if you force a
toddler to wear a mask and then make
them one day when you're five years old
you'll be able to take off the mask
they're just gonna believe you so they
are breeding
a generation of robots and that's what
they want they want a bunch of dependent
depressed robots i'm sorry there's just
no other way to look at that i just
don't know how you could possibly see it
any other way and remember he was
supposed to be the good guy he's not as
crazy as lefty lunatic bill de blasio
that's what they said um and i'm sorry
if you if you now have a child that's
three years old and you are living in
new york city under the rule of that man
you're a child abuser in essence i don't
see a way around it you're a child
abuser you are letting the state abuse
your child put your children in mass we
know kids are getting mouth sores it's
causing delayed speech and depress all
of the stuff
you all know all the stuff and if you're
just letting them do it then uh
congratulations your kids are going to
put you in a really really cheap old age
home one day where you'll most likely be
abused by one of their friends but
there's more from new york city because
some parents have had it he said that
the good he made it seem like the
parents want this right this is what the
parents want because i love parents uh
not exactly the truth we've got some
info here from the new york post roughly
a hundred parents and children gathered
in front of new york's uh city hall
monday to protest continuing mass
mandates for the city's youngest kids
there is nothing i wouldn't do to keep
my daughter safe but it is my fervent
belief a belief supported by science
that continuing to mask two to
four-year-olds is unnecessary said dr
megan martin who has two children's
two children ages six and four masking
tauts hampers their development and must
be abandoned she argued the policy does
real harm to their education and social
growth she said and it was the oath i
took as a physician to first do no harm
that is bringing me here today the rally
goers said they plan to file a lawsuit
that will challenge the ongoing face
covering requirement for children for
and under if you want to know sort of
what level
what level of abject [ __ ] we're
dealing with do you remember what
happened a week ago today do you guys
remember what we were doing a week ago
today remember we ordered some pizza and
some tequila and we watched that elderly
man give that ridiculous speech where he
slurred all his words yeah i remember
that that was a week ago that was the
state of the union that was joe biden
he's 81 years old is that right how old
is joe biden something like that or he's
78 81 whatever he is but the guy's
obviously not doing so great with a
bunch of other geriatric old people most
of them who have trouble standing up out
of their chairs he's 79 years old thank
you
but he acts 81. um they were all in a
room
that was closed that was not outdoors
uh and they were hugging and kissing and
spitting all over each other nancy
pelosi was rubbing her evil claws
together remember that as she sat right
behind old joe um
the day before that joe was wearing a
mask that day he didn't wear a mask the
day after he was wearing a mask again
it's all theater it's all [ __ ] i
just don't know what you what they have
done how did they take the [ __ ] thing
out of your brain that makes you think
but they did it and congratulations to
them for being very good at what they do
even though they're very evil
but which is more dangerous which is
really think about it please scientists
if you're a scientist if you're a media
matters guy who watches my show please
help me
please help me please show me the study
that shows me it's more dangerous for
three-year-olds to be unmasked than joe
biden and nancy pelosi please show it to
me but i get
that you can't do it i know you can't